cần chữa bài tập tắt hẳn cái đi
Ờ hôm nay Như tiêu đề thì các bạn thấy
là hôm nay nên là một buổi tâm sự gì đó
như có vài người à bảo với tôi là nên có
một buổi tâm sự cuối năm hoặc là đầu năm
tùy Tôi không biết để tiêu đề như thế
nào với tôi Thực ra thì ừ Thực ra là với
đa số mình thì thực ra thì Tết Tết dương
là không quan trọng đúng không Mình quan
trọng Tết âm
à thô rõ ràng mình vẫn là người dương
Nhiều lúc tôi vẫn thắc mắc cái đoạn đấy
không biết là đấ rõ ràng là chuẩn là
Ờ
mình có Nhiều lúc mình sẽ tính theo lịch
âm Nhiều lúc mình tính lịch dương đúng
không
này hơi ghê để sao cái này
à rất hạnh phúc cái này chắc để xong hai
cái này chắc là để các bạn xem sau nhé
rồi tôi
sẽ nói con điểm bản thân sau con
đầu tiên thì ngồi khoe các bạn đã Vâng
tôi sau hơn một tuần bị bệnh về mắt cuối
cùng đã trở lại
mạc cái đấy theo như tôi tôi khám thì nó
là do vi khuẩn gì gì đó nghĩa là không
phải là
do không phải do kiểu
như nào nhỉ bị lâ hay gì gì đó chỉ đã
khái là do vi khuẩn virus gì đó tôi nghĩ
là do có thể là do hệ miễn dịch mình yếu
kết hợ việc là mình không thường xuyên
Vệ sinh mắt kiểu là không để mắt bị khô
rồi Vân Vân đ cả là mình còn hay sử dụng
nhiều thiết bị điện tử giống như là ngồi
máy tính cả ngày xong rồi Lúc mà ngủ tôi
vẫn còn nằm lướt điện thoại khi mà trong
trong phòng tối đấy thế nên là tôi
khuyên mấy ông thì chắc là
ờ theo như bác sĩ khuyên nhá thì đó là
không nên dùng mấy cái nước rửa mắt kiểu
dạng mà nó có tí cay cay à Nói chung là
đại khái là không không cần phải dùng
mấy cái loại nước r mắt đấy mà chủ yếu
dùng cái nước mắt nhân tạo là tốt nhất Ờ
tiếp theo là
à mế không phải để hạ sử dụng nhá Cái
quả nước mắt nhân tạo của tôi hôm trước
tôi vừa mới xem nó chỉ có bốn tuần từ
khi mở nắp rồi đấy tiếp theo còn gì nhỉ
dụng màn hình bé mấy ông thấy Thực ra
tôi toàn zoom chữ to vãi chưa Tôi cũng
nói chung là càng đúng kiểu Tôi đang
thuộc lại người già xong mấy ông tôi bắt
đầu ngồi chỉnh cỡ chữ to r xong rồi làm
mọi thứ cũng kiểu chậm hơn là Vân Vân Ờ
để ý sức khỏe nhiều hơn các thứ
cạnh cạnh giường nữa nên mấy ông Nếu giả
sử kiểu bí quá phải sử dụng điện thoại ở
trên giường cũng nên có cái đèn ngủ gì
đó được nên tối om ánh sáng ánh sáng từ
từ máy tính nhìn vào nó là ánh t ánh
sáng không tốt ánh sáng xanh à ánh sáng
trắng thì nó không tốt Nó sẽ kiểu cũng
không khiến cho mình bị à nó khiến mình
khó ngủ hơn nữa đ ngủ lên đèn màu vàng
ví dụ ngay bây giờ là tôi cũng đang có
cái đèn treo ở trên màn hình máy tính
bây giờ này nó kiểu để tốt hơn cho mắt
đi Nói chung là tôi càng ngày tôi càng
chủ trọng hơn rất nhiều cái
à Nên nên dùng cái tiện ích để nó là
2020 à i chẳng hạn hay gì đó ie tôi tắt
sư đi rồi hồi trước có cái tiện ích của
anh anh tôi đi Có dạo như lâu rồi tôi
không mở bởi vì gu anh cái khác hồi
trước r nhưng mà ý tưởng ấy khá là hay
cứ 20 phút là Hiển l ảnh cái để cho mình
ngắm để cho bổ mắt cũng một cái
ờ nên đại khái là có một cái tị ích gì
đó nhắc nhở thì 20 phút ông đứng dậy
thường là nó sẽ có Khải niệm 20 20 20 à
là 20 phút mình đứng dậy nhìn ra 20 m
trong vòng 20 giây đấy hoặc tia Mấy em
xinh xh ở phòng bên cũng được
đấy nếu mà tiếc không cẩn thận thì lúc
đấy mắt ông lại thâm
sử kể cả ông không cận nhá thì ông vẫn
nên có kính để chống ánh sáng xanh xong
rồi chống vân vân nó cũng đỡ phần nào
Nói chung là
ờ đại khái như xế tôm trước nói tuy là
mắt có hai cái thật đấy nhưng mà nhưng
mà vẫn phải biết bảo quản giữ gìn vì
tính ra nhá tính ra thì
ừ
Nói chung đại khái có rất nhiều cái nó
tự chữa lành được nhiều bộ phận cho cơ
thể ông nó kiểu cơ thể mình thấyc ra rất
là thông minh để mà tự chữa lành được
rất nhiều cái mắt Thực ra cũng có nhưng
mà nó mắt nó rất là hạn chế để mà tự
chữa và nó còn
bị nó là một trong những cái lão hóa gọi
nhanh nhất à và kiểu sớm nhất à Tôi nhớ
mang má là như thế nên kiểu mình phải
cẩn thận nó các thứ thứ và thự cả cái gì
mình chả CN cẩn thận
có kính chống cơm
chó chắc là kính đấy bây giờ phải dành
cho người gì gì
đó đúng rồi mắt dễ bị lão hó nhất tôi
tôi nhớ có đoạn đấy bởi vì bởi vì tôi
thức ra một cái Điển hình thôi đó là tôi
nhớ Tôi đọc một cái đó
là mấy ông biết được một sự thật thú vị
đó là mắt mắt mình không hề thay đổi
kích thước ngay từ bé tí đến đến khi
trưởng thành không Thế nên thường mấy em
bé mắt to ấy đấy nĩ â chỉ ngay từ và nó
cũng gần như ít hay đổi nhất từ ngay từ
bé tí đến khi trưởng hành đấy và vì nó
kiểu dạng là mấy cái bộ phận kia của ông
nó sẽ phát triển lên đến mức độ đó xong
nó ra đi đúng không Thì cái này chỉ Dạ
nó phát triển rồi sau đó thì nó lão hóa
nó không có kiểu phát triển lên gì cả
đấy anh dùng gì để codt trên m cũng vậy
thì tôi dùng p ST không phải trả phí mà
tôi dùng tôi cũng kiếm được cái meu để
mà không mất
Ờ tôi nói chung là bị mắt thế tôi phải
kiêng chuẩn là để khỏi hoàn toàn thì sẽ
mất một tháng Ui cái bệnh viêm giác mặc
này nguy hiểm phết đấy hôm hôm đấy tôi
ngủ dậy Tôi cứ tưởng là tôi bị thiếu ngủ
nên là tôi kiểu bị đau mắt Nhức mắt thôi
nhưng mà lúc mà lên công ty thấy ai cũng
thấy kiểu Ui mắt mày đỏ Lom ấ các thứ
thứ không phải đỏ kiểu đ mặt đỏ đâu mà
đỏ kiểu mắt giống như kiểu saran à mayy
Bị một bên kiểu các động các kiểu mạch
máu các thứ thứ ở trong mắt ấy thì tôi
đi khám luôn mấy ông không nên mấy ông
không nên đi khám anh mấy không nên sợ
đi khám tôi cái này Thực ra hơi ngoài lề
một tí nhưng mà tôi thự ra tôi rất ngại
chia sẻ về kiểu bản thân kiểu để tìm sự
đồng cảm hay thương hại gì cả nhưng mà
nhưng mà tôi phải nói thật là tôi là một
người cũng hay bị ốm vặt và rất kiểu
không hẳn rất nhiều bệnh như đại khái
sức đề Khang nó yếu mà nên là việc Tôi
đi bệnh viện Rất rất nhiều rồi Ngay từ
bé chứng mà Nên là chắc tôi không sợ
bệnh viện lắm nhưng còn rất nhiều người
ở đây tôi biết là kiểu sẽ kiểu sợ bệnh
viện thậm chí là sợ đi khám này sợ kiểu
sợ uống thuốc vân vân đấy mấy ông đừng
có sợ một cái kiểu thế bởi vì giả sử như
cái bệnh này của tôi này à Tôi lập tức
đi khám ngay chiều hôm đấy Xong rồi bác
sĩ bảo là kiểu bệnh này rất là nguy hiểm
May mà mình phát may mình phát hiện sớm
ấy vì không thì nó sẽ làm thậm chí mất
hoàn toàn thị lực cũng có đấy nên là nó
khá là nguy hiểm mà kiểu mình không nên
kiểu kiểu ra Bắc ra hiệu thuốc Long băm
các th thứ để chữa mà mình vẫn nên đi
khám đúng
V cũng rõ về cái vụ đấy Đấy xong rồi Thế
nên là tôi cũng phải kiêng
kiêng trong thời gian kiêng đấy thì tôi
tôi nói chung là tôi cũng tìm hiểu qua
trên mạng về bệnh của mình hỏi chbt đủ
kiểu vân vân Nói chung là để mà biết rõ
được bệnh mình các thứ các thứ thô kiêng
kiêng cái gì Vâng vâng trong Trong
khoảng 3 4 ngày gì đó không sử dụng máy
tính
rồi rồi kiểu dạng thậm chí là tôi còn
mới đầu tư quả máy chiếu không ạ máy
chiếu để mà ngồi nằm xem phim cho nó to
chứ không nằm xem trên điện thoại nữa
nhưng
mà
Ừ tại Xem sắc tanh rồi tự nhiên thấy sản
phẩm của người Việt mua ủng hộ luôn cũng
kiểu người có tiền rảnh rỗi đấy đấy th
Đấy lý do nhá đó
là mình rảnh mình ha hai tiêu tiền nên
mấy ông phải bận mấy ông ạ bận kiếm tiền
hay bận làm gì đó chứ không giảnh th ng
ở nhà nghĩ quần tiêu tiền nhiều không
đấy
Ờ rồi
Ờ xong rồi cái quả máy chiếu còn không
biết kiểu lắp đặt các thứ thứ cứ tưởng
chiếu lên tường là xong Hay lúc đầu
trông mờ vãi chưởng
C Đang định kiểu pass lại nhưng mà mà
lúc sau May mà chỉnh được Bây giờ ngon
lành rồi đấy ch đã có thể nằm trên
giường Xem phim giái trí V tính là tôi
không có
tiv thường Bây giờ chẳng ai có tivi à có
tivi giờ cũng chỉ C nối mạng để lên trên
mạng thôi
động chỉnh à Cái loại rẻ tiền à rẻ tiền
này thì không đắt gấp đôi thì có
đủ dị để khó làm cái vụ đấy vì tưởng anh
cũng nghiêng một góc nào đó mà
Ờ đấy Xong rồi sau 3 4 ngày thì cuối
cùng tôi cũng ngồi cốt nhưng nhưng tôi
vẫn khẳng định mấy ông là
Ờ tôi chắc là tôi bị ám ảnh gì gì đó nên
là trong những khoảng thời gian nghỉ kia
tôi chỉ nghỉ mắt thôi chứ não thì vẫn có
vẻ vẫn hoạt động vẫn nghĩ về code vẫn
nghĩ về kiểu mình xử lý bài toán như nào
vân vân nên thành ra thành ra là kiểu
khi mà
à Hai ngày cuối ngồi code tôi ngồi code
xong hết toàn bộ những cái mà đáng lẽ là
trong tuần vừa rồi đá lẽ phải ngồi cốt
nhưng mà lại phải nghỉ
đấy Nên là
Ờ tôi luôn Nói mấy ông đó là thực ra lập
trình viên mình không phải là cứ ngồi
cắm cúi vào ngồi làm ngồi cầy mà thực ra
là mình mình chỉ cần có tư duy ể lập
trình và mình nghĩ về bài toán đấy Xong
rồi cái việc code là lúc mà mình chỉn
giản mình diễn giải ra thôi diễn giải
mọi thứ ở trong đầu mình ra thôi Lúc
code không phải lúc hồi nghĩ mà mình nên
nghĩ hết mọi thứ đã x ch khi code thì C
rất là ít rồi đấy Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ làm
như thế ho thậm chị bây giờ chuyển qua
ngồi cốt Giấy à kểu Thế để đỡ hại mắt
nghiệm về rever an có thể chia sẻ kinh
nghiệm về phát triển Red team sau này
không ạ
không biết chia sẻ gì cả
Ờ ông thừa hỏi chat gvt với vụ này V gần
đây là Tôi thà khuyên các bạn như thế
bình thường chước tôi bảo mấy ông trả
Hỏi Google Nhưng bây giờ sẽ à Không bây
giờ quên mất Giờ chúng ta nên hỏi Google
Nhưng mà không hỏi không Hỏi Google bình
thường nữa mình hỏi Bin đi nghe nói là
dạ này Bin ăn đứt được cả chity rồi m
không chể qua hỏi Bin nhá Bin a ấy có vẻ
ngon phết
đấy Bin Đúng không nhỉ À đâ nhầm xin xin
lỗi nhầm nhờ bass bass của Google chứ
nhá m ông chuyển qua hỏi bass Google thi
thi thử hỏi xem thử ví dụ
Đ dịch ra ông bụt
à đây lần đầu dùng hô trước trao Google
nó hiển thị ra thôi chứ Đây nó tính ạ
lần đầu rồi
À
muốn học bảo mật để vào vé team
thì cần học những gì Hình như là tôi nhớ
là nó còn đề xuất ra cả Ờ để s ra cả
những trang web luôn ấy tính ra nguồn
tính ra là nguồn kiến thức Google trang
web nó vẫn xịn nhất mà Đúng
không các Khải niệm về pla
đấy học ở trang nào chẳng
hạn
lời Trung Trung thôi nhưng mà vẫn có vẻ
đỡ đây Trang web trung tâm đào tạo đây
đây đây có mấy kiểu xem mấy cái này để
mà bấm vào xem các th thứ nữa cũng được
mà try hack
thậm
thôi nội dung chính của kênh là gì vậy
ờ đầu tiên thì đầu tiên các bạn biết đến
kênh của mình là để dạy để học lập trình
miễn phí Ờ nhưng mà mình mình ghi mô tả
của kênh không hề liên quan đến cái việc
học lập trình cho dù của playlist như là
như thế là tên của kênh thì không kiểu
không phải là ờ long lại lập trình hay
là hay là tôi đi codt Long ha à Long đi
codt dạo hay gì gì đó mà
Ờ tôi để tên là blog tức là chị là tôi
muốn tôi muốn là Ừ không phải về mỗi lập
trình mà code là kiểu đấy thì chia sẻ
tâm sự mọi thứ kiểu theo góp nhìn của
theo như tôi mô Tải đây voer này wibu
này Ờ à 96 học it này không gì nhỉ dân
Navi này đấy
à trung đại khái thì tôi
a đương nhiên là tôi vẫn là dân công
nghệ thì chắc là chia sẻ về công nghệ là
nhiều nhưng mà tôi định hướng không phải
về mỗi công nghệ nhiều cái khác Nói
chung là là
nó nó phục vụ Chắc là phục vụ cho cá
nhân tôi là nhiều hơn là tôi thích kiểu
Tôi là người thích chia sẻ nên thành ra
tôi đây là một cái kênh để tôi chia sẻ
mấy ông cảm thấy phù hợp với cái cái
kiểu cách chia sẻ hay là những cái gì
tôi thấy hay ho tôi chia sẻ lên mấy ông
thấy cái gì hay mấy ông tham khảo đấy
khó để mà nói là kiểu kênh Cụ thể một
cái gì á nó nó na ná nó n ná giống như
là J2 cũng thế J2 lúc đầu là đúng là là
một nhóm lúc đầu hoặc là vụ vote forum
cũng thế lúc đầu chỉ là một cái diễn đàn
một cái kênh về công nghệ Nhưng mà khi
mà các dân công nghệ lên đấy nói chuyện
chán về công nghệ rồi thì họ tâm sự hay
là thảo luận về mọi thứ mọi thứ có thể
theo góc nhìn của Ừ Tao là dân công nghệ
Tao là dân tri thức hay vân vân đấy nên
là tôi cũng nghĩ là nó là một cái gì đó
tôi không hẳn là tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ mở
một cộng đồng để cạnh tranh về cái điều
đấy bởi vì cũng có hàng kiểu trăm cộng
đồng khác thế rồi nhưng
mà Thì tôi nghĩ là đây là một kênh kểu
anh em biết đì nhau chia sẻ thôi tính ra
thì tính ra thì
ờ không thì mình biết chia sẻ đâu đúng
không Thế Tôi sẽ để tên nó là Block chứ
không phải cái community hay cái gì đó
video trên YouTube có nội dung bằng
tiếng Anh Ừ Nói chung là ba nó tiềm năng
hơn nhiều
trước tôi đang định nói đó là mỗi khi
tâm sự như này hôm đấy tôi sẽ mở cam lên
bởi vì thường hồi trước là tôi bảo không
không mở cam là bởi bởi vì không phải
tôi ngại kiểu cho mấy ông xem mặt đâu
vôn dĩ là tôi có ẩn danh như thế đâu
toàn bộ ảnh cũng đang hết lên rồi mà ảnh
toàn là ảnh dìm nên thực ra tôi chẳng
Thực ra tôi không ngại bị dìm gì cả Đôi
khi nó là một cái m gì đó tôi cảm thấy
là ờ Tôi từng nói mấy ông chưa nhỉ thì
Hoàng nó cứ bị lạc chủ đề tí thông cảm
nhỉ Nhưng mà tôi từng nghe cái vụ là một
cái thứ Nó tồn tại lâu ấy là thông qua
Min không biết mấy ông biết vụ đấy chưa
Nhưng mà nói chỗ là tồn tại và lan
truyền được rộng là qua
Min phát âm đúng từ m nhở
thì thì có rất nhiều cái nó rất là vĩ
đại rất là kiểu nói chung là xịn chất
lượng ấy nhưng mà không có mem nói về nó
dần dần nó sẽ bị lãng quên có rất nhiều
cái mà tự nhiên nó sống lại hoặ Nó tồn
tại đến bây giờ bởi vì có rất nhiều m
chế về nó giống như rro chẳng hạn đấy
thì
ờ đại khái là như thế nên là tôi không
ngại việc là nó có tí kiểu không cần
mình phải háo nhoáng mình có thể gì à
Ờ trông rất là bình thường giản dị và
kiểu rất là hài rất tố hề các thứ thứ sẽ
được làm m đ ạ hoặc là kiểu à Cắt clip
ra để mà chia sẻ gì đó chong hay mà chúc
là tôi cảm thấy là vui khi mà người khác
kiểu đón nhận mình không nhưng mà hôm
nay đúng là trông t thật đề hôm khác
chuẩn
Bôn C
nhiều năm Uầy xịn
kinh nghiệm C nghe kiểu bây giờ lương
của tôi chắc phải được trảm Bitcoin rồi
xịn
chatb 4 không không thể cạnh tranh được
về bass và đặc biệt là gần đây đến chính
cả CEO của bạn còn của chity còn thừa
nhận là ch cà ngày càng lười hơn mii bây
giờ nói cứ bắt nó cứ phải nhắc lại câu
lệnh thì nó mới kiểu mới làm ấy Nó kiểu
càng ngày càng lười nó càng ngày càng
trở được tắt ấy không biết Nó học từ ai
tệ thật đấy gi như con người cũng thế
thôi nhưng mà Nó học đấy Đúng kiểu học
xấu con người à trả lời kiểu không đầy
đủ ấy tệ cực kiểu may Nó chưa trả lời
mức cợt nhả thôi Sắp đến giai đoạn về
xong nó trả lời mình cợt nhả kì thế mà
mày cũng phải hỏi à đấy kêu
thế đấy thức ra cái điểm hay là như thế
đó là hỏi ai hơn tra Google bây giờ Bởi
Vì à Vì chạ ch Google bây giờ nó sẽ
không kiểu nó sẽ không cố hiểu mình và
nó sẽ kiểu Ít ra nó chả đầy đủ hơn
Google vân vân vân đấy nhưng mà bây giờ
ai mà nó còn
kiểu
kiểu tắt ha kiểu trả lời cho có nữa thì
rồi
Chịu Nhưng mà thực ra cũng hơi buồn cười
đó kiểu ai học từ mình nhưng mà nhiều
người lại học từ ai nữa nhiều người tìm
tài liệu hay là học hỏi từ ai
nữa ừ thì nó cũng là một Đi đường vòng
nĩa Thay vì mình học từ người khác thì
giờ mình học từ ai ai học từ người khác
một thời gian nghỉ nhiều người sẽ nghĩ
rằng là ờ thì mình bị may một kiến thức
rồi các thứ thứ nên tôi cảm thấy
là nó phụ thuộc vào Tư duy và mọi thứ
của mình bản chận bản chất mình Làm lập
trình viên không phải là mình chỉ cắm
đâu vào code theo tôi một dân công nghệ
và đặc biệt là một lập trình viên nói
chung thì là một người có tư duy kiểu
logic các thứ thứ và sử Lý mọi bài toán
không phải mỗi lập trình
nhá mọi thứ trong cuộc sống nó cũng theo
một cái logic một cái trình tự gì đó
kiểu các thứ nên là không phải nói là
sau một thời gian ông không codt thì ông
Ừ thì có thể ông quên mất kiểu các hàm
các thử các thứ nhưng mà tư duy Ông vẫn
phải có không phải sau một thời gian não
ông bay mất không không Ờ trừ khi là sau
một khoảng thời gian đ ông không sử dụng
não thôi não ông vẫn ở đấy mà đúng không
n theo tôi thì sau một thời gian Tôi vẫn
code được Và thậm chí code còn bay hơn
lâu lắm không code ấ nghiện thử thử xin
hãy Chào em Chào bạn bạn có tên
là Quang Huy Đấy may Tôi không tên được
Quang
Huy Tên đấy là tên của cái thằng cướp
người yêu cũ của
Ờ hôm qua thì tôi
tên con như thế
À hôm trước thì tôi có đọc cái này là
kiểu đương nhiên là gần đây gần
đây đặc biệt năm vừa rồi Tôi cảm thấy
năm vừa rồi là một năm mà tôi phải thay
đổi nhân xưng quan rất là nhiều vì tôi
cảm thấy Ừ thì mình tôi biết được là
mình chưa chắc chắn là không phải là
hoàn hảo hay cái gì gì cả Còn rất nhiều
thứ sót và mình cũng có cái tôi và có
cái bảo thủ riêng của mình à Nên là nên
là vẫn cần phải thay đổi sửa đổi
nhiều nên là tôi lắng nghe ý kiến mọi
người khá là nhiều và cũng thay đổi theo
à Không hẳn
là Ừ thì có nghe Nhưng mà ở đây quay lại
một tí đó là mình vẫn phải biết được bản
chất của
mình bản chất của mình là con người như
thế nào à mình sẽ không thay đổi cái con
người cái cái vốn dĩ gọi là nhỉ Thôi
chẳng biết dùng từ gì để diễn tả bây giờ
nó là nó cái riêng của ông ấy mấy ông cứ
hình dung như thế ví dụ Giả sử Giả sử
nhá Tôi là người kiểu dạng là
ờ thoải mái trong rất nhiều cái này tôi
không quan tâm về vật chất này tôi là
người kiểu sống vì đam mê này ồ kiểu Tri
thức này còn thậm chí là trông gầy này
đấy Kiểu kiểu có thể Ờ tôi tôi cứ đại
khái là như
thế thì tôi sẽ vẫn muốn giữ mấy cái kiểu
như thế Dù sau này có xảy ra vấn đề gì
xảy ra bất kỳ cái gì tôi vẫn muốn giữ
mình là con người thể muốn người thoải
mái không bị gó bó bởi bất kỳ cái gì cả
đặc biệt liên quan đến kiểu không thể bị
đồng tiền chi phối chẳng hạn Tôi muốn là
như thế thôi Không biết về sau thế nào
tôi sẽ cố để không bị điều đấy kiểu xảy
ra
đấy Thì ý tôi là như thế nghĩa là khi có
một cái vấn đề gì đó xảy ra à hoặc là
khi ai đó khuyên mấy ông thì mấy ông Dy
nhiên là mấy ông cũng nên lắng nghe xem
thực sự là người ta muốn khuyên mình
theo trừ hưởng tốt lên hay người ta chỉ
kiểu muốn thay đổi mình theo kiểu là bởi
vì nhiều người nhiều người đưa Lời
khuyên ấy thực ra không thực sự là quan
tâm cái điều này có tốt cho ông hay
không người ta chỉ đơ giả là muốn ông
như thế thôi nó n là giống như là tôi
từng nói về mấy ông là sẽ
gầy như như là
ờ cái bản chất của lời chúc của rất
nhiều người ấ ví dụ ví dụ điển hình Bây
giờ tôi chúc mấy ông có người yêu này
chẳng hạn đấy có người ông có nhiều
người sẽ cảm ơn Ui Em cũng muốn có yêu
thật anh chúc thế tốt quá nhưng có nhiều
người thì không em thích độc thân mà tự
nhiên anh chúc em có yêu th kiểu thế rõ
ràng là mình chúc cái thứ mà có thể là
mình muốn Hoặc mình nghĩ là số đông muốn
như chứ chắc người kia đ muốn đúng không
Thì thực sự là cái đấy có phải thực sự
là điều tốt không M N cả nhiều người ở
đây tôi nói thằng hơi phũ một tí thì là
đến chính bản thân tôi gi cũng thế đó là
mình nên phát triển bản thân hay là mình
nói chung mình phải xứng đáng đã rồi
mình mới nên có người yêu chứ Bây giờ mà
có người yêu nhiều ông gọi là tôi nói
thẳng là chưa trưởng thành ấy xong rồi
người yêu cũng trẻ con ấy hai người trẻ
con cùng với nhau ấy nó nó sinh ra nhiều
vấn đề lắm Nó còn khiến nhau bị mệt hơn
ấy đấy khẳng định như thế nên là nên Nên
là gọi nh
à nhưng thế thế nên là kiểu Ai bảo ơ ông
có người yêu vui vậy nếu ông kiếm người
yêu để cho vui ấ Thì đấy là một trong
những cái suy nghĩ
sai rất sai luôn
đấy Nói chung là
ờ đúng rồi ng có tình yêu có rất nhiều
giai đoạn rất nhiều cái thứ thứ thứ
nhưng mà đừng
kiếm đ cho vui kiểu các thứ
sang cái đời Xa quá nhng cái đại khái
như thế nghĩa là à lời chúc hay là mọi
thứ người ta khuyên chưa chắc là hoàn
toàn phù hợp với mình mình vẫn phải vẫn
phải tự điều chỉnh sao phù hợp với mình
đúng không ạ Mình vẫn phải giữ được cái
bản thân bản chất của mình thì nhưng mà
tự nhiên tôi nhắc đế bản chất người tốt
ở đây là gì không biết mấy ông biết cái
câu chuyện này chưa Nhưng tôi từng đọc
rồi tôi a Tôi không nhớ lắm Tôi chỉ
chích không trích chính xác được nhưng
đại khái Tôi nhớ là câu chuyện này về
nhà sư về con bọ cạp thì phải
ờ nhà sư thấy con bọ cạp bị rơi xuống
dãnh nước xong rồi muốn vự kiểu cứu con
bọ cạp mu cầm nó lên thì con bọ cạp Nó
thấy thế nó tự vệ Nó kiểu nó Chích vào
tay nhà tay nhà sư như nhà sư vẫn cố để
mà kiểu cứu nó thì lúc mà mọi người bảo
Tại sao lại cố cứu nó thế khi nó kiểu cố
muốn làm hại mình ấy thì thì nó thì nhà
sư bảo là bản chất của nó là nó tự vệ là
như thế còn bản chất tôi bản chất của
tôi là tôi muốn cứu cứu nó đấy nghĩa là
làm chỉ là mình cũng phải mình phải giữ
được cái cái mục đích cái suy nghĩ cái
chính kiến riêng của mình cái tại cái
thời điểm mình làm một cái gì đó cũng
phải như thế Tức cả sao tôi không biết
tôi kể mấy ông câu chuyện đấy chưa Nhưng
có rất nhiều câu chuyện mà tôi từng gặp
chính tôi cũng là
cũng bị cái tâm lý Như Thế Đó là ví dụ
điển hình nhá điển hình cái này không
biết mấy ông dính chưa Tôi khẳng định
được là có vài được người ở đây bị dính
rồi đó là ông đi tặng quà cho một bạn
Ờ xong rồi bạn đấy từ chối không nhận mà
qua đấy ông chuyển qua cáu bạn đấy mới
ông cặp vụ đấy bới gi chư ạ không Hoặc
là không cần phải tặng mà chỉ rng là ông
giúp một ai đó x người ta từ chối hoặc
người ta kiểu gì kiểu đấy Kiểu phủ nhận
nó sờ ông chuyển nó cáu ghét kiểu Tao
giúp mà mày không trân trọng C thử thử
mấy ông ở đây từng gặp
chưa Rõ ràng là nếu thế thì tại mình
phải suy nghĩ lại tại sao mình lại
giận rõ ràng là mình lúc đầu mục đích
của
mình mục đích của mình đôi khi lúc đầu
đúng nghĩa là mình muốn giúp người ta
muốn người vui muốn người ta kiểu
Ừ Thì đại khái là muốn người ta vui đúng
không ạ nhưng mà tự nhiên mình thấy
người ta từ
chối kiểu không cần mình ấ mình Chử C
ghét thế tôi Tôi không biết mấy ông từng
bị thế tôi đúng là tôi từng kiểu như thế
Suy nghĩ hơi ích kỉ Chắc
nằm ở mình chứ không phải vấn đề từ nằm
người ta không phải người ta phủ nhận là
người ta ghét mình hay gì cả
mà đôi khi nó chỉ đơn giản là kiểu người
ta không cần thôi và mình phải nhớ được
cái bản chất Mục đích lúc đầu của mình
là mình muốn người ta vui mà Thì người
ta vui khi không có mình cũng được thành
phải chấp nhận điều đấy vui khi hoặc
người ta không Tạm thời bây giờ không
cần điều đấy Mình nghĩ người ta cần như
thực ra không
cần đi làm việc có làm việc với CH lô
nhiều không
ạ Tôi chưa từng gặp công ty nào làm việc
qua ch lô cả cho nó thường ha dự án cá
nhân hoặ dự án nhỏ hơn hiu trong một
team hơn không không ở công ty đâu công
ty tôi dùng ra này bản thân jira cái
atlanta gì gì đó không nhớ để chính xác
tên lắm atlasia hay gì gì đó nó mua
chính công ty đấy nó mua lại cho này
nhưng nó vẫn giữ cái thằng zira bởi vì
thằng zira mới chuẩn cho công ty chứ cho
ra không phù hợp công ty lắm đâu À đấy
thì quay lại câu chuyện kia thì đáng lẽ
là chuẩn làm mình làm cái gì đó mình vẫn
theo tô vẫn phải nhớ lại cái mục đích
ban đầu của mình thực sự là mình vì mình
hay vì người ta đấy Và nếu m v vì mình
thì mình phải giữ được cái bản chất của
mình không
phải giống như nhà sư đấy nghĩa là tôi
nói nhà sư nghe nó kiểu cứ bị Thiện quá
kiểu Tôi đang dạy Thiện mấy ông các thứ
không đến nỗi là kiểu tôi dạy đời mấy
ông đến nỗi cũng thế nhưng ý tôi là à
mình không nên để bị ảnh hưởng bởi người
khác người khác xấu không có nghĩ mình
phải xấu đúng không ạ Và thậm chí người
khác tốt không có nghĩa là mình phải tốt
Mình có thể vẫn xấu Nếu mà Mấy ông vẫn
muốn giữ cái bản chất đấy đúng
không Đừng nên Thy Ờ gì Hồi trước có cái
câu nói đừng nên thay đổi vì ai cả đấy
kểu Thế cũng đúng mà Ừ nghe thấy nó hơi
bị bảo thủ một tí nhưng mà nghĩa là
những cái gì mà nó Ông cảm thấy là nó
mới nói lên con người của ông ấy thì ông
có thể giữ ông thay đổi vì người
ta kiểu quá rồi ông tự đánh mất chính
mình thôi Tôi nghĩ là như thế Nói thế có
hơi bị bảo thủ Quá không chắc không đâu
nhưng mà Đúng là bảo thủ
với bảo thủ với A gọi nhờ có chính kiến
nó mong manh
lắm Cho em hỏi được không Em cứ hỏi đi
tí anh còn chữa bài tập
sử mà ông làm việc xấu tốt hơn việc tốt
thì tôi nghĩ ở có kh ông nên nhờ không
thể nói nên tiếp tục làm việc xấu
được Nói chung là th xấu hay tốt thì nó
vẫn là liên quan về vấn đề đạo đức hay
vân vân
thôi Cái đấy thì tôi lại khó nói cái đấy
tự ông phải xem xét lại đạo đức của
tự nhiên tôi lại ghi cái nểu này nhỉ Ừ
đôi khi tôi để cái tiêu đề nó hơi mơ hồ
qu đây tôi đọc cũng không hiểu lắm
Ờ như nào nhỉ
nhưng mà cảm thấy
là nó hơi dậy Đơi quá nó tính xong thôi
Chắc là chỉ ngắn gọn lại cái vụ đó là ờ
hơn đúng đúng rồi tôi tôi nhớ được đoạn
này À đúng rồi Tôi nhớ rồi đó là hồi
trước tôi đọc được một cái đó là Thay vì
mình dùng từ xin lỗi mình hãy nói cảm ơn
Thực ra tùy thường trường hợp V có nhiều
cái quả nó không nên đâu như cảm ơn mày
đã chơi đều tao ấy không hay
Ờ nhưng
nhiều hơn mình nên trân trọng nhiều hơn
và nói từ xin lỗi tính ra nó vẫn bị nặng
nề quá ấy đấy Nên là nên là kiểu thay vì
đấy mình đôi khi mình nói từ cảm ơn
người ta trân trọng hơn các
thứ Ok nhỉ ví dụ giả sử như hôm trước
tôi vừa phải cảm ơn ông em ở đây khi mà
nó phải kiên nhẫn đợi tôi chẳng hạn đấy
th ra cũng xin lỗi cũng xin lỗi nó nhưng
mà cảm ơn nó vẫn nghe nó đỡ
hơn đừng xin lỗi Hãy đổ lỗi
mà đúng không Đừng xin nói chung là hạn
chế nhất là xin tôi thì thực ra là tôi
không biết mấy ông nà tôi tôi hình như
tôi còn chưa nói mấy ông về khái niệm đi
xin việc mà gần như là nó sẽ đi ứng
tuyển Hoặc là đi
kiểu kiểu đi làm ở công ty nà Đó mình
hạn chế dung từ xin nhất có thể mình
chẳng phải xin ai cả Nói chung là đại
khái thì
chế dung từ sin luôn đấy để để sao cho
kiểu
ư kiểu dạng là mình trân trọng chính bản
thân mình đã nãy giờ thực ra tôi đề cập
vẫn là cái bài toán quay định quay đi
quay lại thử ra nó gộp lại vẫn chỉ bài
toán việc là bạn phải trân trọng bản
thân mình trân trọng sức khỏe mình rồi
các thứ các thứ đúng không gọi là phẩm
giá bản thân à Vân vn không biết dùng từ
mấy cái từ đấy Hoa Mỹ không Tại khái thì
mấy ông trân trọng ông người khác mới
trân trọng được Ông đúng không ạ và
đương nhiên mình cũng phải trân trọng
người khác nữa nhá chứ không phải mình
trân trọng bản thân kiểu thượng đẳng quá
hơn người khác thì không đúng ng trận
trọng mọi thứ đấy được không ạ tiếp theo
có bạn hôm nay hỏi tôi ngành tester còn
hot không tôi hôm đây tôi trả lời đó là
ở ngành nào còn ra tiền thì còn hot em ạ
Thế Chỉ đơn giản thế thôi ngành nào còn
ra tiền thì tức là ngành đấy xã hội vẫn
cần mấy ông biết cái khái niệm e không
không phải isk is nhầm xibu rồi mất rồi
niệm gì
nhỉ nhở ông ông nào gọi ý th quên mất
cái t
gì nhở Tại sao mình nhớ Nhầm V từ này
nhỉ À à isik chuyển sinh
vibu Thế là sao đi kỳ thị với ông vibu
khác
thường chia sẻ mới ông một lần rồi nhưng
mà TH thành thản nhắc lại vì có mấy ông
ở đây mới xong mấy ông còn quên đôi khi
tôi hồi trước tôi có cái ảnh trên cái
album verer của tôi ấ là bài học quá
nhiều nên chúng ta sẽ đôi khi quên c mấy
cái bài học đấy Nên thỉnh thoảng mình
phải nhắc lại bình thường đấy là kiểu
dạng là đây những cái gì Ông giỏi này
những cái gì mà ông trả tiền cho à cái
này là xã hội trả tiền cho ông mới đúng
đúng không À không mấy ông mấy cái ông
kiếm được tiền đúng rồi m cái ông kiếm
được tiền này mấy cái ông yêu này và mấy
cái thế giới cần này đấy thì bản chất là
mấy ông đầu tiên thì tôi quay lại bài
toán ở đây là ông nên không nên làm
những cái thứ mà kiểu thế giới không cần
đúng không í nhất thế giới cần đã nếu mế
muốn kiếm tiền thì chắc chắn là phải thế
giới thế giới cần đã đúng không
đấy thì thì ông làm thế kiểu ông Ông
không cần quan tâm à cái việc quan tâm
việc cái ông giỏi này thực ra ông cứ tạm
bỏ qua đi Cái gì ông thích làm này mà nó
kiếm được tiền thì tức là là thế giới nó
cũng sẽ cần với nó kiếm được tiền mặc
định là hai cái này tôi nghĩa là nó ôm
bao gồm cả cái y k này rồi đấy đúng
không cái gì ông thích làm và ông kiếm
được tiền từ nó sẽ này có thể nó kiếm
được ít nhưng mà thực ra là là tôi hồi
trước tôi từng nói nó kiếm được ít thì
chỉ đơn giản ông làm chưa đủ giỏi thôi
còn nếu mà ông làm đủ giỏi như này đúng
không Thì thì tiền nó lên Thế thôi mấy
ông thấy là cái này nó không nối được
sang cái này không ạ Thấy không có cái ở
đây đúng không ạ vởi hiển nhiên vởi rõ
ràng ông chỉ cần làm đững cái thứ ông
ông thích và nó kiếm được tiền thì nó đã
là y ik rồi không cần quan tâm với việc
cái bên này cái bên này làm gì cho nó
trông vẻ phức
tạp đúng không Mà ông hiểu mà đúng không
Đây có tiếng Việt này Đấy rõ ràng là ông
thấy cái này nối sang cái này cái này
nối sang cái gì gì đó Nhưng rõ ràng Cái
này nối thẳng trực tiếp đến cái này thì
nó là y y r gì á đúng không
là bạn làm tốt hơn thì kiếm được nhiều
hơn đúng không
À thế nên là cái mà việc là ngành nào
còn hot hay không được Ông đừng quan tâm
việc là ông cặm thấy ông thích nó hay
không Và nó còn kiếm được tiền hay không
còn kiếm được tiền tức là là ông vẫn thể
nhảy vào thế thôi còn việc cạnh tranh
các th thứ thì ngành nào chẳng cạnh
tranh ông không thể mong một cái miếng
miếng ngon để dành phần cho ông được trừ
khi ạ đặc biệt là trong ngành IT này nhá
Còn ngành khác thì có thể là ông còn giữ
được một cái ghế ở đâu đấy kiểu quan hệ
các thứ cò ngành này ra đến cả cái ông
đang ngồi yên trong đấy còn bị đào thi
ra được n thành ra là không ấy nói là sợ
cạnh tranh ông tự mở ra thì ông mới
không Cạnh tranh thế
từ đâu á
Ừ trên mạng có mấy cái về Python đấy em
học Python cơ bản đi
á Tìm Lại Cảm hứng đam mê lập trình em
cảm thấy đánh mất nó rồi á
Ừ anh hồi trước anh kể về vụ là hồi
trước anh làm được hẳn một cái đồ án rất
là xịn kiểu thuyết trình được 10 điểm
nhưng anh vẫn cảm thấy chẳng hào hứng gì
cả cái cái hào hứng này Thực ra là còn
liên quan đến tùy mỗi người ví dú Giả sử
Bởi vì anh không bị chi phối bở đồng
tiền nữa nên thnh à Kiểu cái việc kiếm
đượ nhiều tiền nó không khiến anh hào
hứng hơn
ờ anh anh thích việc chia sẻ nên là cái
hồi mà anh làm cái lập trình này xong
anh chia sẻ cho mọi người mọi người đón
nhận thì kh anh cảm thấy vui đấy ít ra
anh còn biết được anh thích một cái gì
đó và anh cảm thấy anh làm được cái gì đ
đem lại giá trị cộng đồng thì anh cảm
thấy vui Có khi em cũng có thể làm một
kiểu như thế hoặc là em chyển giản là em
thích những cái khác ví dụ em thích làm
má móc em thích tìm hiểu mình mò có ông
em ở đây có nhiều ông em ở đây là cũng
kiểu thích m mày mò tự học này x lập
trình thấy cảm thấy là phù hợp vì hợp
việc mày mò đấy Nói chung là cái việc
thỉnh thoảng mất cảm hứng lại Nó là một
chuyện cũng anh thấy cũng bình thường
bởi chính Ông anh của
anh một ông anh trong J2 cũng cũng chia
sẻ với anh là
cũng cũng bị mất cái đam mê lập trình
nhưng mà chỉ sau một tuần sau đấy thì
thấy ông anh lại đâu ở đấy rồi nghĩa là
mình làm đôi khi nó còn theo thói quen
nữa vân vân nên khó để mà trả lời được
cái câu hỏi tìm lại các thứ này lắm Cái
này xuất phát từ bản thân em em thật sự
em cảm thấy em thích gì em muốn gì
và đừng để để bị áp lực khác nó đè vào
được bởi anh cảm thấy là nhiều người bị
phải dùng những áp lực khác để mình để
mà mình bắt tay vào làm cái gì đó ấy thì
đấy Không Còn Là Cảm hứng nữa Cái đấy là
gọi là cái gì khác rồi
đấy đừng đừng để bị cái đấy Nó tác động
vào thì
tiền đâu Ai trả tiền
không xếp không
trả em ông lung Java web B en quá anh
ơi tôi
không Tôi không làm ja vaa nên tôi không
biết khuyên ông cái gì ông cũng hỏi Câ
chung chung quá nên tôi Mung lung Neo
ông rồi anh từng làm recomend system
chưa Không thực ra tôi vẫn chủ yếu vẫn
làm là tôi tô chư trước nay code chỉ có
mỗi web
này và ra và tiện ích thì nhớ ông em C
hộ nhưng chủ yếu thế chung quy lại vẫn
là web này chắc là về sau tôi sẽ đụng
thêm à Về app Chắc thế nhưng web nhúng
app À nhầm app nhúng web đấy Ờ Còn mấy
cái khác thì tôi không dành lắm đâu Mấy
cái đấy ông nên hỏi này
ấy có ai trả lời được thì trả lời
Ừ hình như là tôi nhớ không lầm h trước
nhớ câu chuyện của một ông anh J2 Hồi
trước cũng từng kiểu đến một cái giai
đoạn cũng vấn đề về tâm lý cũng kiểu một
tháng bỏ code để ngồi chơi game xong rồi
chơi đế phát chán rồi Cuối cùng thì từ
đấy Không chơi game nữa cắm tay và làm
tôi không thể khuyên ông cái kiểu thế
được vì mỗi người một
khác nhưng mà như tôi vừa bảo thì nếu mà
ông không giả sử là ông không còn một tí
đam mê gì kiểu không còn thích một cái
gì Nữa của lập chỉnh ông sẽ chuyển hướng
giống như hồi trước tôi chơi là là bài
toán là người đồng hành người đi cùng ấy
ông kiếm yêu xong rồi bảo yêu chúc ông
lúc n ông lấy đấy làm động lực đấy một
cách
hoặc làm trang web kiểu hôm trước là tôi
cũng thử làm trang web kiểu dễ thương dễ
thương các thứ thứ ý đấy con gái thích
cái đấy mà Đấy đấy là một cái động lực
cho mấy ông đấy các bạn nữ nữ mà không
biết về công nghệ nhìn mình kiểu trông
cũng kiểu một cái gì đó kiểu vĩ đại mình
thấy thích rồi Nói chung
là bài toán ở đây nó vẫn quay lại đó là
là ông phải thích cái biết được mình
thích cái gì đã còn nếu mà bản thân ông
chưa biết được mình thích gì
thì thì không ai trả lời được cho ông
cái đấy cả ông phải ông phải thử hết mọi
thứ khác để ông biết được là ừ hóa ra là
cái này phù hợp với mình nhất Kiểu như
thế còn nếu mà tính ra ông chỉ phù
có vài người tôi cảm thấy đúng là vô
vọng thật họ chỉ phù hợp việc chơi game
thôi mà chơi game họ cũng chẳng giỏi
luôn Chẳng qua là họ kiểu bị không không
có động lực làm nhiều thứ nên họ C cắm
mặt vào game nhưng mà chơi kiểu gọi là
chơi giết thời gian qua ngày ấ lúc đấy
thì bề tắc lắm Tôi không biết khuyên mấy
ông kiểu gì luôn
Ờ vể chính mấy ông còn tự chôn mình vào
trong cái đấy
Ờ ông có thể cắm mặt vào làm một cái
việc khác cũng được trong khoảng thời
gian mà chưa tìm được cái động lực hay
đam mê cho
em thoải mái tí thì lại học không hiệu
quả mà lo thậ trương học thì không thể
cuộc sống vui anh không không biết
khuyên em như nào Nhưng Hồi trước anh
chưa từng học vui khi học nhưng mà
anh kiểu mình nghiện ấy nên mình chơi
rất là
nhiều Nghiện nghiện nghiện ở đây nghiện
nhiều cái khác nhá Nhưng đại khái thì Ờ
nhưng mà khi đến giờ học thì anh vẫn đi
học thôi anh vẫn kiểu dạng biết được là
nó nó quan trọng và nó tốt nên vẫn khi
học thì anh chảng nghĩ gì đến game cả
Còn khi chơi game anh chả nghĩ đ học cả
cách Bạch được tất cả những cái đy khi
đi làm Bây giờ anh thấy đi làm thì anh
chỉ cắm mặt vào làm anh không ngồi chơi
không làm bất kỳ cái gì khác thỉnh
thoảng kiểu lướt lướt tí ảnh Cho có động
lực thôi còn đâu chủ yếu vẫn làm việc
các thứ các
lắm kiểu ừ
Nói chung là luôn phải giữ cho tâm trạng
mình thoải mái bởi vì đặc biệt là cái
ngảnh của mình cũng đặc thù là liên quan
đến chí não thì não mình mà căng thẳng
quá nó cũng chảng nghĩ được cái gì cả
đấy mình vẫn nên để thoải mái thức cả kể
cả việc khác theo kiểu là việc không
phải là cần y quy nhá mà kiểu cần sáng
tạo thì tôi nghĩ cũng cần phải thoải mái
Nói chung là bây giờ tôi nghĩ là vẫn
quay lại vấn đề vẫn là thoải mái Đúng
không nhỉ còn thoải mái theo cách nào
cả nó vẫn nằm ở bản thân bạn Tôi chẳng
biết khuyên cái đấy cụ thể như nào bạn
cần kiểu biết được Thế nào là thoải Mai
với bạn nhất thì bạn làm thôi không thì
bạn cứ thử những cái công việc khác để
xem cái nào mới thực sự phù hợp với mình
chắc phải
lý trong khi làm việc nhóm bài tập lớn
muốn
học Anh có kinh nghiệm hay phương pháp
nào để có thể team Quốc hiệu quả không
mà tôi làm sinh viên thì thì mình tôi
gánh hết nên tôi chẳng biết khuyền mấy
ông về cái khoản team Quốc với các bạn
các bạn là như th nào tôi Hồi đấy tôi
cũng phân công mỗi ông làm một mảng như
mà tính ra mấy ông ấy làm để một cách
tạm bở chấp vá Sau Cuối cùng thì mình
vẫn phải tự làm hết nên cũng
không khó nói cái
đấy nhưng mà để về nói việc là bây giờ
không không khó trả lời được cái câu hỏi
là về kỹ năng quản lý con người vì tôi
cũng không giỏi quản lý con người nhá
quay lại quản lý công việc thì giống như
bạn vừa nãy nói là có thể thể dùng cho
rồi xong rồi để mình quản lý hết toàn bộ
công thông tin công việc trên đấy mình à
chia các đồ mục ra tự mình để để để tự
mình kiểu
ư xem tiến độ mọi thứ như nào thực ra
mình vẫn phân công cho mấy ông kia nhưng
mà mấy ông kia không làm được thì mình
cứ ghi lại đầy đủ cái điều đấy xu lúc mà
báo cáo thì báo cáo Giả sử ông ở trưởng
nhóm hay gì đó ông Báo cáo lại với giáo
viên là em làm hết toàn bộ phần em em
phân công cho cho em rồi làm tốt rồi Có
những cái phân mà Ông mấy ông kia được
phân công mấy ông không làm thì đấy việc
mấy ông đấy Em không có thời gian để
gánh hết tất
cả Em chỉ hỗ trợ được các bạn ấy thôi rõ
ràng ra vì bản chất đi làm mà cũng sẽ
gặp đúng kiểu có người này người kia mà
có rất nhiều người là kiểu người ta
không làm việc hoặc người ta làm việc
kiểu đối phó ấy thì việc đấy là sếp của
ông sẽ xử lý không phải ông đúng không
Nếu không giỏi bài toán của con người
ông chỉ làm nhân viên thì ông chỉ cần
làm tốt nhiệm vụ của mình à hỗ trợ được
người khác thì tốt còn không thì mình
làm việc của mình chuyên nghiệp và được
không cần nhất thiết phải gánh hết toàn
bộ đúng không ạ Làm sao một người thể
gánh hết được Nếu thế thì đâu phải bài
tập lớn bài tập cá nhân rồi đúng không
hướng đi Chúc mừng em em
Em đang đi đúng đường đấy còn một khi mà
em kiểu mới học mà tự nhiên em thấy được
hướng rõ ràng khi em đang đi sai đấy chỉ
có mỗi chơi đồ thì thì kiểu một lúc là
em đã nhìn thấy kiểu sáng lạn thôi Thế
còn tất cả những cái ngành khác công
việc thì lúc đầu học đều mù mờ như nhau
cả thì kiểu dạng thì ông ông làm gì có
chuyện ông học kiểu học một tí học trong
vòng 1 2 năm nó cũng có thể kiểu biết
được Kiểu tương lai sáng lạn rồi làm đì
chuyện
đấy bản chất là học mấy cái này nó nói
chung là cảm quá trình rất là dài thường
là kiểu được phí nhiều người thường ha
ví giống như kiểu tập chim hay tập phải
dục gì gì đó cái ông sẽ không bao giờ
thấy cái cái tác dụng của nó ngay nhưng
mà về sau ông mới kiểu sau sau phải rất
lâu một khoảng thời gian V sau ông mới
thấy được cái kết quả đúng không ạ thôi
Bảo ơi chỉ có chơi đồ thì không mới thấy
luôn nữ
để bổ sung năng lực cho sinh việc vậ anh
khi đi thực tập rồi xong rồi Hoặc là
trong thời gian đi thực tập thì vẫn làm
các dự án các thứ thứ thôi thì tự trình
nó sẽ
giỏi là tự làm hết ờ cũng chẳng biết
nhận xét là người giỏi hay không nữa vì
tự làm hết cho gì Đúng chắc chắn là ông
ông nên có trách nhiệm và ông nói chung
là đại khái ông phải bắt tay vào làm
việc nhiều người kiểu thấy bạn
mình nhiều người thấy bạn mình ngồi chơi
cũng cũng ngồi chơi treo Thế thì cả hai
đều tệ đúng không ạ thấy tấm gương xấu
như thế mình mình mình biết được là nó
xấu đúng không ạ Mình không Đâm đầu ở
đấy Thế là mình đã tốt hơn rồi đúng
không ạ Thế thôi coi như là mình hãy su
Hay là cứ phải suy nghĩ theo kiểu nó cứ
th thực tế đi Đó là một thằng đã bị loại
rồi mình đỡ phải cạnh trannh với
nó có một sự thật đôi khi nó tàn nhẫn
như thế đó là tuy là tôi khuyên cho tất
cả mấy ông ở đây bây giờ nhưng mà tôi
không thể chúp được tất cả mấy ông bây
giờ đều thành công đều tốt được vì tất
cả mấy ông thành công đều tốt thì thì
đào ra ngần đấy công việc cho mấy ông
Đào đấy đào đu ngần đầ xuất cho mấy ông
sẽ có việc là mấy ông ở đây bản chất
đang tự cạnh tranh với chính nhau đúng
không ạ Ông
này đương nhiên là tôi vẫn muốn giúp đỡ
hết sức có thể mấy ông nhưng mà ông nào
mà gọi là ông nào mà tận dụng được ông
nào mà kiểu chịu khó được được thì ông
ấy bứt lên còn ông nào mà kiểu vẫn tiếp
tục như thế thì mấy ông đang bị mấy ông
khác cướp việc đúng không ạ Công việc
chỉ ngần đấy
giờ đang có 10 Ông đang ngồi than thì có
tận hai mấy ông hay ba mấy ông ở đây
đang ngồi cười yeah tao có việc rồi còn
bọn mày thì không kểu Thế không nghĩ là
như
thế
hết rồi mà lên lớp bấn điện thoại rồi
nhờ bạn gánh Đán đến khi ra trường thì
thôi Đúng đấy Thế mấy ông Thực ra mấy
ông không cần so sánh mình với bản thân
người khác tôi đúng là đúng là tôi nhiều
lúc tôi cũng như thế thật tôi cũng để ý
người khác nhưng về sau mình cũng phải
gọ không nên soi mói Hay là bận tâm
người khác mình lo bản thân thôi đúng
không Mình không cần để ý người khác làm
gì cả đấy nó như nào thì cuộc đời nó tự
quyết định đúng không ạ kể cả cho dù giả
sử về sau nó kiếm được việc mình không
thì mình cũng đừng có nên so sánh hay
trách gì cả Mình đi kiếm công việc khác
và biết được ở cái công ty kia chắc đểu
mới tuyển nó cứ suy nghĩ kiểu lạc quan
thôi tôi phỏng
vấn p vòng tex đến vòng nói chuyện với
co xong h 3 4 ngày liề không chưa thấy
HR liên hệ lại khả năng tạch
không tạch thì tôi không chắc nhưng chắc
chắn là nếu mà không tuyển ông ngay một
là công ty có vấn đề vấn đề đây đôi khi
vấn đề kiểu gi không cần tuyển nữa hai
là hai là cũng có một ông p giống như
ông Mỗ tội ngon hơn nói chung rất nhiều
cái nói chung là trong thời gian này thì
như tôi bảo thì ông mấy ông vẫn không
nên kiểu nộp hồ sơ xong hay là phỏng vấn
xong rồi ngồi
chơi mà vẫn luôn tự cải thiện trình độ
mình để
mà thậm chí là đấy đi đi phỏng vấn cả
chỗ khác nữa chẳng vấn đề gì cả phỏng
vấn chứ có phải ký hợp đồng rồi đâu nên
là mấy ông hoàn toàn thấy
kiểu sang xem thử nhiều bên các thứ thứ
mà anh làm việc vậy Có tập thêm thể dục
thể thao gì không
ạ Vừa nãy tôi vừa yêu cầu à Vừa khuyên
mấy ông Cải thiện sức khỏe hay sức g
kháng xong Đúng tôi vẫn sẽ phải cải
thiện
à Sức khỏe tôi gần đây tôi có à Thực ra
tôi mua cái dây tập và xe đạp cũng nửa
năm rồi tôi sẽ phải tôi sẽ phải chăm
chút bản thân sức khỏe hơn
Ờ tôi đang định à Bây giờ tôi sẽ sắp xếp
lại thời gian để bắt buộc sẽ còn một
ngày của riêng mình để mình gọi là một
ngày mà chẳng đi chơi đâu cả Chỉ chỉ
kiểu Một ngày tự kỷ kiểu như thế để
mà làm mọi thứ ch bản thân nế Cải thiện
sức khỏe các
bị deadline gì
á Cái này tôi không biết như nào Tôi
từng Tôi không biết chắc là tôi từng bị
deadline gì hay không Tôi nghĩ là có
nhưng mà bản thân tôi không được coi Nó
là một cái deadline gì cả tôi làm đúng
kiểu vì đam mê mà nên nghĩa còn công
việc thì tôi vẫn cứ làm đương nhiên là
nhiều lúc cũng rất là cắn Hằng nhưng mà
sếp tôi cũng không Ờ dí tôi rồi cả chắc
là ở trong môi trường thoải mái nhưng là
tính ra thì để mà thực sự là ông làm đủ
đúng giờ
các thứ thứ nó khá là khó trong cái
không phải trong mỗi it Mà mà trong rất
nhiều Công việc bây giờ đúng là các sếp
rất nhiều nơi các sếp nó kiểu cứ bóc lột
sức lao động mình Các th thứ nên việc bị
bị kiểu dí một cái gì đó là chuyện bình
thường Cái quan trọng là mình phải chấp
nhận cái việc bình thường đấy mình khó
nhiều nơi nhiều ông thì chấp nhận thật
nhưng mà đôi khi Thế bị quá đáng quá
nhiều ông vùng lên cũng chẳng giải quyết
vấn đề gì cả Nói chung là
Ờ cái việc cân bằng này chắc là do mỗi
cá nhân của mấy ông thôi Nhưng mà người
ta cũng có khuyên một cái mẹo ấy đó là
ông hãy luôn làm cho cảm giác giống như
ông đang rất là bận rộn hoặc là khi ông
làm cái gì đó đấy Cho dù kể cả cái vài
cái nó nó là dễ nhưng ông hãy khiến ch
nó cũng là cũng một cái vấn đề gì đó
quan trọng để à Kiểu hơi hơi khó một tí
để cho xếp vào trân trọng thành quả của
ông đấy trong trường hợp xếp xấu nhá Còn
nếu mà xếp mà Lý Tưởng cũng tốt tốt
giống như kiểu bên tôi ấ kiểu rất là
trân trọng sinh nhân viên ý thì cái việc
đấy rất là thoải mái theo kiểu là ông
làm gì ông cũng sẽ được ghi nhận ví dụ
giống như là bạn tôi vừa chia sẻ à Giống
giống như là tôi tôi làm cái vụ này tôi
đã định nói luôn vụ này thì ông lại đế
cập thì kiểu à Hồi trước tôi được giao
cái vụ tối ưu kiểu bởi vì nó bị chạy
chậm rồi nó cũng bị làm treo luôn cái
database ấ tôi mất 3 tháng r tôi ngồi
sửa tối ưu cái đoạn đấy Xong rồi 3 h đấy
Tôi không làm một cái việc gì khác chỉ
làm mỗi cái tas này thôi tối ưu bởi vì
công ty tôi là công ty product tức là
sản phẩm riêng công ty nên rất phải cháo
chuốt các thứ thứ cẩn thận nó xong sau
ba tháng nó vẫn không thể nhanh hơn được
mấy đấy xong rồi lại phải đập điể làm
lại các thứ B hàng đấy nghĩa là toàn bộ
code B hàng đấy công cấp luôn bởi vì Thử
dự án khác không khá th đật đấy thì Sếp
tôi vẫn trân trọng Nói chung là bởi vì
công ty tôi là trả lương theo tháng nữa
không phải trả lương theo kiểu đã làm
được bao nhiêu bao nhiêu ấy nên lương
thì tôi vẫn đ nhận đủ và sếp vẫn trân
trọng năng lực hay mọi thứ của mình
không coi mình Thằng vô dụng kiểu ch làm
được cái gì cả giống như hôm trước tôi
đă một cái satus ấy đó là không phải là
không phải là em mất cả sáng em chỉ làm
được mỗi thế này mà em mất cả sáng để Em
khẳng định là nó chỉ có thế này Đấy đấy
là do cách nói cái tư duy của cái góc
nhìn của ông là như nào khi mà ông nói
thế với sếp sếp cũng chẳng thể nói gì
Ông cả vì nó đúng nĩ th kiểu không phải
cả sáng em chỉ làm được mỗi này thôi à
Không cả sáng em em mất cả buổi sáng đ
Em khẳng định là nó chỉ có thấy này
thôi nghĩa là không cần phải làm hơn nó
nó thế là đủ rồi
đấy Nói chung là tôi nghĩ là rất nhiều
cái rất nhiều cái ấ mình hoàn toàn thể
thay đổi được cuộc sống mình tốt lên là
do cái góc nhìn của bản thân mình thay
đổi góp nhìn một cái vấn đề gì đó mình
thay đổi là coi như là mình mình sẽ mình
mình mình nói chuyện với sế mọi thứ nó
cũng khác ngay Nhưng mà thực sự là như
bạn tôi chẳng hạn bạn tôi vừa chia sẻ vụ
là kiểu nó m một tháng làm một cái gì đó
xong rồii Cùng Sếp bảo bỏ đi xong rồi
xếp C không trả lương nó những kiểu như
thế thì đúng là khó chấp nhận thật nên
là tôi vẫn hy vọng là mấy
ông Đương nhiên Đương nhiên là đầu tiên
mình phải hi vọng Mấy ông không thất
nghiệp mấy ông kiếm một công việc đã
Nhưng mà khi mà kiếm được rồi thì mấy
ông vẫn nên luôn cho chút bản thân V
mình vẫn còn có tuổi mà thể kiểu ứt phá
các thứ thứ được để mà kiếm công việc
hoặc là để xếp phải ghi nhận xếp phải
xếp phải nhà nâng lưu trân trọng mình à
để không bao giờ bị dính vào cái hoàn
cảnh kiểu mình cần xếp C xếp không cần
mình rất là tệ đúng không ạ
thực cả bây giờ mấy cũng không biết nào
Nhưng mà thực ra là là đặc biệt trong
ngành an rồi nhá xio Còn đang bị đuổi
việc mấy không biết vụ đấy không ạ Bởi
vì lương của C bây giờ thực ra là kiểu
gì nó dần dần nó cũng sẽ tăng ấy nên là
thành ra nhiều ông bây giờ lương thậm
chí bằng gấp hai hoặc gấp ba lần của một
Junio mà trong khi đó Bây giờ ai nó hỗ
trợ tận răng rồi nghĩa là một Junio có
thể ngồi dùng ai cũng có thể ngồi code
như một coo rồi hoặ Thậm chí là nói
chung là một coo không thể nếu mà không
có những bài toán rất là khó ấy mà công
ty cứ tàng tàng toàn việc dễ thì thì một
xo làm sao làm việc bằng hai ông jio gộp
lại được hiệu suất sao bằng được nên là
nhiều co bây giờ phải xin là không tăng
lương hoặc là thậm chí là bị đuổi có rất
nhiều vụ như thế rồi rồi chứ đừng có
nghĩ là việc là mỗi Junior khó kiếm việc
bâ giờ xo còn không kiếm được việc cơ bị
đuổi xong không kiếm được bởi vì mấy ông
ấy không chấp nhận mức lương của m Chino
đâu
việc em nằm vùng toàn tiền toàn bàn khóa
học bởi vì mấy ông tham gia ở những cái
mà hiển nhiên là người ta kiểu mấy ông
cạnh tranh ít rồi mấy ông phải chủ động
hơn nó chỗ là tôi nghĩ là th ra hơi khó
vì tính ra tôi cũng toàn được người quen
để giới thiệu Ừ đấy nhưng mà chỉ Nếu mấy
ông cực kỳ giỏi ví dụ bây giờ tôi có vài
ông sinh viên giỏi Tôi đang đị giới
thiệu nó đến một đâu đấy thì nó bảo nó
được việc Hết rồi Được kiểu cũng vào một
chỗ người quen ho kiểu có người nó tìm
nó hết rồi n mấy ông cũng phải thể hiện
ra ngay từ lúc mà trên cái nhà trường
mới không phải đủ kiểu tốt ấy để các
thầy cô hay mọi thứ mọi người xung quanh
có thể giới thiệu việc cho mấy
sẽ đi thc tập hiện tại đã biết nên luyện
thê gì nếu có Châu
chặc thực tập fen fen thì
thì tôi vẫn thích kiểu full stack hơn
tôi có dạy trên khóa của tôi là theo
kiểu là back end đấy full stack ấy Nhưng
mà thực ra code để dàn tư duy th ông có
thể tham khảo
qua thực c ông thích theo kiểu làm fen
theo kiểu ra scp
thôi thường Bây giờ nó chẳng tuyển fanel
về mỗi scrip đâu thì
tập team á anh Thực ra là anh thường Hồi
trước anh vẫn thiên hướng Vẫn kiểu dạng
là không muốn thân mình mình đôu con
kiểu nói chung là để tập cho khỏe lắm cả
để cho săn săn lại thôi săn chắc lại
thôi chứ không phải kiểu kiểu cơ bắp
cuồng cuộn nên anh vẫn Thiên hướng là
tập kiểu Chắc là nhẹ nhàng à Không biết
đúng không Nói chung là tập về sức bền
ấy kiểu tập võ hoặc là mấy kiểu dạng
hoạt động khiến cho mình kiểu đương
nhiên vẫn là tập mà đương nhiên là kiểu
Ờ th kiểu tập chạy này nhảy dây
Ờ hoặc là đạp xe hoặc tập võ ở nhà nữa
Anh tập võ ở nhà nói chung là đại khái
để cho mình nhanh nhẹn khỏe
khoắn Anh thích kiểu thế hơn
laragon thấy thầy em bảo làm dự án to
thì không ổn vẫn phải về sampi là sao ạ
Tại sao ai đi khuyên s vậy nhỉ
rồi con tí an nó tiện hơn rất là rất là
Ờ nhưng mà nói chung là về cơ bản tất cả
đều là máy ảo thôi nhảy sang hết đố cơ
em ạ chẳng chẳng ai dùng lagon ha sampi
mấy
nữa chia sẻ về cách
à Đọc đc đi anh tôi kh Tôi không biết
chia sẻ mấy ông như nào Tôi từng kể vụ
là tôi bản chất là tôi cũng không không
phải là người mà ngồi cắm cúi ngồi đọc
tài liệu được ý thỉnh thoảng tôi có vài
trang nào đó tôi đọc thôi hoặc là lên
trang chủ đọc thỉ thoảng thôi nói chung
khi cần thì đọc tôi không Tôi không đọc
theo kiểu nghiền ngẫm nó được vì đọc cái
đấy không nhớ được hết ấy phải thực hành
nhiều mới nhớ ấ nên là bản chất hồi
trước là hồi mà lần đầu động ở lel Tôi
cũng tôi đọc cả mằng này chẳng hiểu gì
cả xong cuối cùng anh ấy bảo tôi cứ làm
các tính năng cơ bản crud đi rồi dần dần
sẽ hiểu Thấy không hiểu đâu thì đọc lại
cho hiểu
đấy cách chuẩn là như thế không cần phải
đọc
kiểu Đọc thuộc đâu đọc làm gì Đọc thuộc
làm gì nó thay đổi theo cũng là theo
từng tháng các thứ thứ thì
chịu anh Có nhận đệ không á không biết
trả s trả lời ông này không tôi Chắc
chắn là tôi chẳng có đệ tử nào th
ờ ai ai cần giúp gì thì cứ nhắn tôi tôi
vẫn nhiệt tình hỗ trợ Và thậm chí dù đi
cà phê thì tôi vẫn kiểu đôi khi là rành
thì tôi vẫn đi kiểu anh em giao lưu tâm
sự nói chuyện Và thậm chí là hỗ trợ được
gì hỗ trợ
Thôi chào thầy Long em học thầy từ đợt
đầu cảm ơn kiến thức và lael như dự án
ngoài đã ra bác em được được 6 tháng rồi
Cảm ơn vì lượng kiế thức Ừ chào em Anh
nhớ tên của em quen lắm
ừ ừ thì thực ra series mới này nó cũng
chẳng có gì lắm đâu Nó kiểu cũng cũng về
bác en về về cái làm cái web kia thì bản
chất là nó cũng về Bắc Nhưng mà chủ yếu
là anh làm chia sẻ kinh nghiệm của xio
em thích thì thì thảng mào xem cũng
được anh Long Có chơi môn chạy bộ không
chính xác là tôi hồi trước thích chạy
nhưng mà Đúng là bây giờ không chạy gì
cả Ừ gần đây m các bạn Tải mấy cái app
để chạy bộ nhỉ hay năm mới rồi cũng sẽ
tải cái đấy rồi Tôi tập chạy cùng các
bạn nhỉ Trông cũng hay hay đấy gần đây
còn mới mua con Tai nghe xịn
nữa thì sẽ có thêm động lực để chạy được
nhưng mà tính là chạy nhưng mà tính là
tôi cảm thấy là chạy kiểu thời tiết lạnh
này
nó hoặc là Ừ hay là mình mình lại nghĩ
việc tiêu tiền mình sẽ đi mua một bộ đồ
để chạy bộ cho nó có động lực chạy bộ
cũng được
đấy
ny cách để đấy thì tôi tôi biết được là
cách để tạo động lực cho tôi là như thế
mà để nó cũng tạo một cái áp lực Vô Hình
như thế tôi sẽ đi mua cái gì đó thì tôi
để đỡ cảm thấy phí tiền thì tôi sẽ phải
dùng
Ờ không hẳn đam mê pp vậy đầu tiên lúc
đầu học pp và kiểu theo được pp đến giờ
thôi còn về còn việc tại sao lại không
nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác vì về cơ bản
Thực ra là thứ nhất là công ty hai là
Mọi thứ không phải công ty này thì công
ty khác vẫn đang cần và đúng là mình làm
lâu rồi Mình hiểu nó thứ hai đó là tôi
không định hướng theo pp kiểu cực kỳ lâu
thế hay là chính xác là không theo Lập
trình lâu thế mà về sau sẽ nhảy
sang chuyên về B theo kể là chuyên về cơ
sở dữ liệu các thứ hơn nên là tôi không
đi sâu về lập trình nó lắm Nên là ngôn
ngữ nó vốn là vẫn là kiểu làm được là
được gi bảo tôi nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác
th kh vẫn làm được như mà về sau tôi vẫn
không hẳn là cần phải quá Tìm hiểu về
nhiều ngôn ngữ hay là tìm hiểu về kiểu
công nghệ mới như ai hay blockchain gì
cả vì bản chất là tôi không muốn Yi sâu
ở Lập trình về mấy cái
dạy js cơ bản đấy thành thả vẫn vài buổi
ngồi mò js còn về dạy cả một kh quá thì
chắc là không đâ vì anh không chuyên như
Ờ ở công ty thì có sử dụng Framework
Finance là view nhưng mà không không anh
cũng kiểu dạng C code người khác Xong
rồi Biết biết
là cơ chế hoạt động nó như nào thôi để
mà sửa chứ cũng không làm từ đầu đâu n
bản chất là đấy thì mình có tư duy lập
trình mình nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác vẫn
làm được nếu mà nếu mà đã có codt sẵn
rồi Mình chỉ cần sửa lại
hơn nóng anh à Ừ để xem Thực ra tôi
không ngại đổ mồ hôi các D th chạy Nói
chung là vẫn được Ừ nhưng mà trước mắt
thì tôi chẽ Chắc là đạp xe đã không mua
xe cũng để đấy Phi
bởi vì tính là xung quanh nhà tôi làm gì
có cái công viên ở đâu nên mẫ ngại chạy
bây giờ chạy chỉ có hít bụi đâ không ạ
ngay cạnh tôi là Trường Trinh chỉ hít
bụi
thôi còn nếu mà không phải Trường Trinh
thì đường khác là đường tắc đường cái
cái vỉa hè không có để mà chạy Nói chung
là quanh tôi không phải là kiểu khu mà
kiểu có cái công viên hay cái gì gì đó
th
bị Ok tôi sẽ lưu ý vụ
quân anh
Nhất n tôi chia sẻ đâu đợi tí tí Đợi tí
tôi Mở map bây giờ mấy ông lại nhìn thấy
nhà nhà
ở đoạn này ngạ tơ sở này
thực ra có thể chạy qua cái Đại học Y có
cái hồ này nhưng mà cái hồ này xung
quanh chẳng có gì c Ờ ta xem có cái công
viên nào gở
gì tô cũng chưa biết chạy cái
gì
biết chạy cái gì luôn ạ không có công
viên nào ở đây cả công viền h nhất ở đây
á Ý ông r tôi bảo tôi chạy bộ từ từ đoạn
này Qua đây
à cũng là một cái hay thứ ra đấy đôi khi
không có động lực thì kiếm ông nào chạy
cùng hoặc kiếm bạn nữ Chạy cùng nó có
thêm động lực chứ tôi nhớ ở đây cũng
toàn người già
chạy không có động lực
lắm Kì kiếm bạn nữ là chạy trước mình
chạy
h rồi có ông kia ở có ông còn bảo là tôi
hay chạy ở kia nữa tôi không ý định là
chạy Chạy cùng ông n
lắm à Chạy cùng ông không sao tôi không
ý định chạy sau ông quên
học xong hai khóa kia của anh rồi em thể
xin Đư th tập ngành được trái ngành được
không thoải mái em mời kênh của kênh bán
chất kênh của anh dạy cho những người
tránh ảnh mà Chứ những cái người mà đúng
ảnh và học giỏi rồi thì kênh của anh
đúng kiểu chả là gì Do họ nên Thánh là
họ cũng không vào xem đâu Toàn bộ người
đây chủ yếu là tránh ngành hoặc là nói
chung là đại khái thì họ cũng cũng gì đó
thì mới vào đây
trước tôi Tôi cảm thấy là sức khỏe tôi
tệ vãi trưởng khi mà đạp xe từ từ mỗi
Bách Khoa về cái Đại học Y rồi Hết sử
hơi mồ hôi vã như tắm luôn mới biết được
bây giờ tôi quá Hiếu
Rồi đến lúc cũng kiểu phải tập thể dục
các thứ rồi chạy qua Thủy Lợi à thủy lợi
ở
ta đã chuẩn bị mở cái thớt ở đây là thớt
chạy bộ rồi anh em vào được nhỉ Nghe
kiểu anh em có kèo chạy cuối tuần chẳng
hạn nghe được đấy Ơ Thực ra tôi có quen
cũng có một nhóm bạn kiểu như thế cũng
bảo tôi nhưng mỗi tội là bọn nó ở tít
tận cầu giấy hoặc ở đâu đấy Kiểu tôi
không thể phóng xe lên đấy và ng nghỉ đ
mà T đi chạy
được được nghĩa là một cái gì đó Đấy
mình nên thế nghĩa bản chất là cộng đồng
mình cũng kiểu gọi là cộng đồng thực ra
kiểu một nhóm lượng người bé rồi xong
rồi anh em
kiểu làm mọi thứ có ích cùng nhau đúng
team Đông Á g hai team ở Hà Nội là hơn
gần hơn Trì người b ông kéo tầm 1000
người chạy cùng ông không khác gì một
cái tổ chức cái gì gì
đó không được không đăng lên cá thử được
thì đăng lên kiểu discord riêng anh em
thôi
Dân chạy quanh tôi Tôi biết chỗ này chỗ
quân đội này bị hút bụi hít bụi nhiều
lắm toàn người ra chạy nữa mình mình đến
hẳn chỗ này không khí trong lành được để
xem tôi cảm thấy nó hay hay để xem được
cứ lên k một cái kèo chạy thử cuối tuần
này đi Cuối tuần này có vẻ à Không qu dầ
này bận mất
rồi sang tuần vậy qu tuần này đi ăn
thiết phải chạy vào cuối tuần hay là gì
gì đó có thời gian mình vẫn nên tập thể
dục luôn Mọi lúc đúng không Tôi cảm thấy
thế Em chỉ đôi khi ví dụ kiểu nửa đêm
này tí tôi livestream xong tôi đi chạy
luôn cũng được một
cách
mình Cải thiện sức khỏe thì mình nên cải
thiện Mọi lúc mà đúng
kêu chạy cùng tôi nhưng thực ra là bỏ
lại tôi chứ chắc chắn là mọi người chạy
xong trước tính ra hồi trước nhá Tôi đã
tự tin Tôi rất tự tin về khoản đôi chân
của
mình đó là Tuy tôi không tổn bể dục tôi
không đá bóng nhưng mà chân của tôi một
phản hội đấy gầy nữa chân tôi không hề
có tí mỡ nào cả ông ông biết mấy cái chỗ
là mỡ mỡ ở cái chỗ bắp chân không bắp
Đúng không nhỉ đúng bắp chân bắp thông
cảm thỉnh thoảng quên mất các bộ phận cơ
thế Bắp chân Đúng rồi cái chỗ bắp chân
này này mấy ông sờ vào chỗ đấy mấy ông
sờ chỗ đấy kiểu đập đập ở chỗ
đấy rất nhiều ông có mỡ ở cái đoạn này
này đấy tôi Hồi đấy tôi đã từng Tự tự
tin là tôi không có mỡ ở đoạn này bởi vì
tôi chạy bộ với chính xá đạp xe là nhiều
và đi bộ rất rất nhiều vậy không ngại đi
bộ các th
thứ nhưng mà bây giờ thì
không cũng có mỡ rồi Tôi cảm thấy là tôi
không muồn đấy tôi bảo là tôi muốn tập
để cho người săn chắc các thứ thứ ấ nên
là bây giờ Mọi thứ đều đang rất là bất
ổn chắc chắn là tôi sẽ phải
làm lại bản thân mình đấy nó cũng là bản
chất của tôi hồi trước đấy bản chất tôi
hồi trước tôi bảo là mình nên gầy gầy à
Vậy gầy không đúng lắm nhưng mà không
phải là
người cứ cho không đầu tiên không phải
người béo đi Tôi muốn là người cũng cẩu
dạng tri thức kiểu mảnh mai ấ đấy nhưng
mà phải săn chắc đấy bây gi bị mất cái
săn chắc rồi mình phải cải thiện lại vụ
thôi chạy xe máy để cho trông đỡ nhiện à
Thế chuyển qua thành thằng trộm chó mất
rồi thì rõ ràng là bây giờ ông trông
giống nghiện thì ông phải cải thiện Ông
tập Sức tập rèn luyện để cho ông có thể
đỡ hơn cho đỡ nghiện hơn
giờ thấy toàn đực rủ nhau như này
thì thì MC chỉ có yêu nhau
thôi chừng nào anh vào Sài Gòn á
Tính ra năm năm trước nữa tôi cũng vào
Sài Gòn rồi còn định tôi nếu mà dự định
tôi tôi sẽ vẫn là thiên về Đà Nẵng vào
Đà Nẵng nhiều hơn lúc vào Đà Nẵng cũng
có thể sẽ có thể sẽ rẽ qua vào Sài Gòn
Nhưng mà thực ra thì ở Ừ chắc là mấy ông
Toàn anh em J2 ở đây Chắc tôi cũng tôi
cũng nói kiểu và đặc biệt là bởi vì có
liên quan gì nhỉ liên quan đến việc
à Sau này n là Nên là chắc là mấy Ông
Nếu mấy ông chưa để ý thì gần đây anh
anh tuần có đă bài đó là là bây giờ tôi
sẽ không còn là kiểu kiềm diệt viên Mode
của J2 team community nữa nên tính ra là
tôi sẽ gần như là bây giờ khó mà để về
sau tổ chức một cái đại diện kiểu th cho
kiểu offline các thứ các thứ cho thành
cho toàn bộ thành viên thì chắc là về
sau là tôi chắc là về sau tôi nếu mà tôi
vào kiểu mấy nơi đấy thì chắc là tôi chỉ
đăng theo kiểu rủ anh em kiểu anh em đi
cà phê các thứ các thứ kiểu à kiểu dạng
rủ Ừ Ờ chắc là cộng đồng nhóm này thôi
chứ không đăng lên J2 để mà kiểu tổ chức
sự kiện to giố như hồi trước nữa nhưng
mà chắc là kiểu gì tôi vẫn sẽ
vàoi vào mấy ông giao lưu cho vui Tuy
mà Hả em giao diện
lời sao giao diện nữ hay là nữ thật hay
là quan trọng ở trên giấy tờ là nam hay
nữ giao diện nữ ở đây tôi cũng từng quen
nhiều bạn nữ giao diện Nam lắm không
biết tôi Thực ra tôi chưa gặp bạn nam
giao diện nữ bâ
giờ không biết trả lời này như
thôi nói cái đ đấy nhạy cảm quá Ừ nhưng
mà Ok em gi gì nữa Ok có vẻ hấp dẫn đấy
chúng ta à chạy bộ trồng thì giao diện
nữa Tức là vẫn ngắm được
Ừ Ok em
h con trai C play nữ cũng được Tôi chấp
hứng phết đấy mấy ông tự lên kèo nhá lên
kèo trong các thứ th có người nhắn tin
này lên kèo trong này nhá Ừ hôm nay tôi
bảo là tôi sẽ chữa bài tập cho mấy ông
kia không biết chữa kịp không t xem
Đây đang làm về sản phẩm muốn một sản
phẩm nhiều biến thể mỗi bến thể có màu
sắc khác
nhau này bộ bổ sung gì không Ừ sku cũng
khá tên sku này cũng khá hiểu
nào product ID này code này code này để
làm gì không rõ này Cái này nối qua cái
này qua ID này ID
attribute ATT ở đây từng cái
này một cái này có
nhiều
này điểm
gì tôi đang chưa hiểu cái đoạn này
lắm à đây chắc là màu Còn đây là đỏ
chẳng hạn đúng không sợi đỏ lại nối sang
đây cũng
được kiểu này cũng được Nói chung là Ờ
tôi từng chữa cho mấy ông về cái vụ cơ
sở liệu nó liên quan đến kiểu các biến
thể các kiểu option như này ở mỗi nơi nó
làm hơ một kiểu thực ra khó để nói là nó
đúng hay sai hoàn toàn lắm V công ty tôi
thì nó còn chỉ có mỗi hai bảng thôi
chẳng hạn nhưng mà cách để nối nó cũng
rất là dị nên khá khó nói và khó để Tìm
kiếm kiểu này thì dễ tìm kiếm này kiểu
này cũng dễ kiểu sửa n là tôi nghĩ kiểu
này không không sai kiểu này cũng được
nhưng mỗi tổi lúc mà cập nhật nó thì
đúng là cũng Liên quan nhiều bản cũng có
vấn đề riêng của nó nhưng nhưng mà khi
mình giải quyết được nó thì cái đoạn này
nó vẫn được tính là chuẩn rồi nó không
phải dùng từ chuẩn mà nó vẫn đúng rồi
không sao
trước
alo nhờ để mà chữa về web thi trắc
nhiệm trông nó khá là lằng nhằng chắc là
tôi phải gọi riêng bạn này ở chữa rồi
nhìn trong là phức tạp hơn tôi nghĩ khá
là nhiều Ừ chắc là tôi sẽ gọi bạn này
chữa
SQL không anh Ờ ở công ty tôi thì có
nghĩa là chể là có những cái không cần
phải theo cấu trúc gì cả thì mình vẫn
hoàn toàn thể kiểu dạng mình mình chơi
noq để cho bản chất là hai hai cái nó
sinh ra hai mục đích khác nhau mà một
cái là để truy vấn nhanh và một cái là
để lưu lại toàn bộ thông tin và nó chặt
chẽ V dữ liệu n cả là để cho mình cái
việc chắc cháy ở đây nó bao gồm cả việc
đúng nữa nên là SQL nó vẫn có gì tốt
thường là tôi thấy là công ty lớn Bây
giờ công ty lớn vẫn dùng n à SQL vẫn rất
nhiều Không sao
m từ chối không
ạ Cái này không biết trả lời thế nào rồi
em ạ Chắc là tạ xin một cái mail khác
hiểu tác dụng của bảng
À cái
A cái này À cái này À thì ví dụ
attribute này là color này nghĩa là màu
ấy thì đây sẽ là màu đấy là màu gì màu
đỏ này bảng này có tác dụng như thế để
biết được là một B đấy Xong rồi màu đỏ
xong rồi màu xanh này xong nó nối sang
đây
cột cái tật Ất và đây tật Ất Thực ra mấy
cột này Xóa đi cũng được trong một vài
bảng thì đúng là nên cần đôi khi là
nhiều lúc mình lỡ xóa đi rồi Về mình c
biết về sau biết tác dụng qu Ôi mình lỡ
xóa cái nguy hiểm cá thử thử nhưng có
nhiều bàng thì tôi thấy là đúng là nó
không ý nghĩa
Anh nhỉ Cái này nói chắc phải nói dài
hơn chứ không nói trả lời ngắn được
như kiểu Win
quantity đúng không À im Em cụ thể là
như nào
nhỉ Chắc là bây giờ cũng một tiếng rưỡi
rồi chắc là tôi sẽ tạm nghỉ ở đây Vì thế
là
kiểu cũng hơi rát họng tí thôi chắc sẽ
nghỉ xong rồi
à Mấy ông cứ đang hỏi ở trong discord
rồi tôi sẽ trả lời dần sau nhá và buổi
và để buổi sau chữa luôn cho Bây giờ
nhiều câu hỏi phết mà không trả lời kịp
được mấ ông nhở rồi còn cái kèo mà đi đi
thể dục thì chắc chắn đ Tôi nghĩ là được
Kèo đấy có vẻ rất là hấp dẫn anh em có
thêm động lực để mà tôi nghĩ là nó một
cái hay kiểu anh em có lý do gặp gỡ nhau
rồi đi chơi Nói chung là đừng có giống
như tô hồi trước là rủ mang tiếng rủ
nhau đi sáng sớm rồi cùng chạy bộ ra
háng
nét đừng thế là
được Chào mấy ông